montréal le 20 janvier 2004
vito rizutto menotté et silencieux il
vient d'être arrêté pour meurtre
l'homme de 57 ans a l'air inoffensif
pourtant on dit qu'il est le parrain de
la mafia montréalaise
un trafiquant de drogue qui a des
contacts partout dans le monde
un millionnaire un spécialiste du
blanchiment d'argent
ce qu'on ne sait pas encore c'est qu'il
était sur le point de commettre le crime
le plus ambitieux de sa carrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est les canadiens ignorent à quel
point le clan rizutto et puissant les
italiens eux l'ont appris en 2005 au
terme d'une longue enquête
[Applaudissements]
ici dans un pays habitué aux crises et
aux chefs mafieux ont décrit les
risottos comme des gangsters
internationaux
ils ont des intérêts économiques ou
quatre coins de la planète et brasse de
grosses affaires illégales sous des
dehors légitime
s'apprête à être candidat mais des
compagnies
au cours des cinq dernières années
l'enquêteur sylvia frenzen et le
procureur adrian uia silos ont examiné
les activités criminelles de la mafia et
des risottos tous les deux cinquièmes de
l'étendue des contacts de la famille
rizutto l'organisation compte aussi à
son organisation peut compter sur ses
contacts dans le monde politique comme
dans le monde criminel qu'on organise de
sonic liminaire biarritz
l'africain
voici canada en
world pour le monde
l'escouade anti mafia italienne est bien
consciente que le blanchiment des
narcodollars est l'une des activités
principales de ces hommes d'honneur
comme ils s'appellent entre eux les
collectivités c'est en 2002 que les
enquêteurs ont appris que vito rizutto
et ses associés avaient infiltré le
coeur même de la société italienne grâce
à un spectaculaire réseaux criminels
ce qu'ils ont découvert dépasse l
entendement pour six ans les autos ce
serait impossible qu'une organisation
criminelle de l'extérieur investissent
dans un des plus gros projets du siècle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce projet du siècle c'est ici qu'il
devait voir le jour le détroit de
messine sépare la sicile du continent il
fait 3 km de large
le gouvernement italien voulait
construire un ton la mafia voulait le
contrat antonio nicaso est un expert du
crime organisé depuis des années il
écrit des ouvrages sur la mafia et ses
activités selon lui le clan rizutto a
bien failli réussir la plus importante
opération de blanchiment d'argent de
tous les temps chauds ebooks google
earth du pro bowl
le projet du gouvernement avance et on
avait dessiné les plans et ont négocié
avec des compagnies internationales la
plus intéressante se trouvait à milan et
personne ne se doutait que ce consortium
avait été mis sur pied par vito rizutto
le clan rizutto était certain d'avoir
trouvé la façon idéale de blanchir des
montagnes de narcodollars il suffisait
d'obtenir le contrat de gestion du pont
domicile et s'assurer ainsi de revenus
propres pour les 30 prochaines années
de retour au hobby la sphère est mise au
jour
et le public scandalisé demande des
comptes comment la mafia at elle pu
infiltrer un projet public si protéger
selon le procureur responsable de l'
enquête c'est que la mafia maintenant un
nouveau visage
un chef capable de convaincre plusieurs
organisations criminelles d'investir
dans les projets d'envergure seulement
une impulsion avec la possibilité d'
état de la disponibilité d argent est
content dit et sabre son été
[Applaudissements]
ce chef avec tant d'argent et de pouvoir
apportant des racines bien modeste voici
cattolica eraclea un village de 4000
habitants dans le sud de la sicile la
vie tôt
la petite maison blanche a longtemps
abrité la famille rizutto les voisins se
souviennent encore de vito enfin que
sera la casse
vito rizutto est né dans une famille
humble son père nicolo était un
agriculteur mais son mariage a tout
changé
la tresse des risottos est encore bien
présente à cattolica à l'hôtel de ville
on a conservé dans de vieux registres
les certificats de naissance et de
mariage
tout le monde ici se souvient d'eux mais
personne n'est fier de leur parcours
criminel comme le souligne le rédacteur
en chef du plus important quotidien si
c'est lié la famille rizutto reste dans
l'histoire du pays
comme bien d'autres italiens ils ont
émigré mais leur histoire est phénoménal
à cause de leurs démêlés avec la justice
un peu
[Musique]
dans les années 50 la mafia locale
contrôlait bien des choses dans les
villages s'il y est comme catholiques à
les emplois disponibles ou même les
élections à cattolica comme ailleurs la
mafia représente une sorte de société
civile et un pouvoir politique
quand les gens voulaient quelque chose
il s'adressait la mafia locale alors
qu'en réalité et y avaient droit
c'était leur droit de citoyen dans cette
mafia locale
nick rizutto s'impose comme un homme
paisible qui préfèrent la médiation à la
violence i was aux personnes qui body
one young world midi show that you can
lead web est finie traille touché
ouattara nbk grille avec la négritude
d'importance aux cherry schelin de par
shirin de wade
la situation de nick rizutto à cattolica
est enviable mais en 1954 il choisi
d'émigrer comme des milliers d'italiens
cependant ces ambitions sont bien
différentes de tout on a dream et au
portugal
la famille rizutto choisi le canada
montréal plus précisément
[Musique]
dans les années 50 et 60 les cabarets
font la réputation de montréal une
réputation de ville ouverte
mais derrière les paillettes on trouve
le monde interlope du jeu et de la
drogue
au fil des ans les familles criminelles
se divise le territoire qui avait
toujours certaines familles qui avaient
des droits qui ça c'est ce à montréal
mais aujourd'hui on a certaines familles
qui depuis des années il on y contrôle
du secteur
il n'y a pas simplement à laver ce
secteur dès qu'il devient policier en
1970 andré bouchard s'intéresse au crime
organisé qui avait des on aperçoit des
jardins ça pouvait des moteurs comme des
ssd scorpions des épouses des cités du
succès ça va comme ça il y avait des
femmes et familles du bourreau mais mme
x wing qui se promenaient mais tout le
monde avait le shakhtar et sa brosse à
vendin tu peux de top d'années comme
enjeu maryse un écheveau 5 et 10 nick
les hutus trouve ici tout ce dont il a
besoin pour nourrir ses ambitions
criminel et il veut la place du chef de
la mafia vic cotroni mais c'est la
famille bonanno de new york qui décide
tout et elle voit les choses autrement
afin d'éviter l'affrontement risotto
quitte montréal pour le venezuela
juste à côté de la colombie le paradis
de la cocaïne selon antonio nicaso cet
exil lui permettra de nouer des
alliances très utile pour le futur qui
est habile internationale
ce majeur times dans leur souris started
to build a network to bring héroïne from
the gold pride glen cook and from
columbia en 1978 paolo violi le
successeur de cotroni est assassiné à
montréal la voie est libre pour les
risottos qui rentre au pays
désormais montréal leur appartient
ils font construire des maisons de luxe
dans un quartier cossu le père le fils
et leurs principaux alliés sont tous
voisins
le clan rizutto agi dans la discrétion
et leur affaire prospère
ce n'est pas eux qui agissent ya
toujours quelqu'un qui agit pour eux ils
ont su cela en arrière et ils font et
est très incertain contrôle de ce qui se
passe pour pokémon de guerre pour
poitiers de guerre de prix pour pompiers
de guingamp gagne parce qu'il ya de
l'argent pour tout le monde dans ce
milieu si la scène criminelle est
relativement calme à montréal c'est bien
différent à new york des conflits
internes déchire la famille bonanno en
vito rizutto est appelée à démontrer sa
loyauté à l'endroit de la famille de new
york
ces capitaux a prouvé qu'il était un
homme d'honneur ou aussi en ahl a
exécuté trois membres de la mafia de la
famille de new york dont on pense qu'à
ce moment là qu'il s'est fait un nom et
par la suite les deux russes par des
familles de niort
[Musique]
après la pause l'erreur fatale qui a
entraîné la chute de vito ok juteau
monsieur appiah sera pas très long est
ce qu on pourrait vous parler un moment
dans quelques questions vous pouvez
[Musique]
la mafia contrôle importation de
stupéfiants
la famille matticks contrôlent le port
de montréal les motards contrôler la
vente de la drogue des alliances
stratégiques se forme
et j'ai taillé facile vanille le droit à
la demande et motardes et motards mais
d'après les calculs pour les sorties et
un port et un montant de l'argent et
matic surtout où il essaie surf est
sorti le logo au gros de l'opposition la
police à l'iris du tout dans sa mine
mais ils sont extrêmement prudents ils
vont gagne on se souvient qu'un agent
double avait infiltré un réseau de
trafiquants d'héroïne qui se
rencontraient dans un bar de la rue
bélanger dans le même bar souvent on
voyait vito rizutto leur rencontre et
des hec
et venir discuter d'affaires est ce que
vous étiez capable de capter les
conversations à ce moment là non non
c'était impossible puisqu'il y avait
toujours quelqu'un jour et nuit avaient
regardé nuit puis non c'était impossible
pour nous de les installer des missions
dans situation et s qui faisait des
affaires à l'extérieur du café aussi du
bar basque ont observé c'est que casio
neil là il sortait du bar et à marcher
de long en large dans un cas sur ronde
est rude pour avoir une discussion
c'est une mafia là qu'on voit dans les
films un cauchemar pour les policiers
incapables d'intercepter des paroles
compromettantes
pendant ce temps la drogue entre par
conteneurs au pays à l'occasion la
police procède à une saisie
et les rares fois où vite au risotto est
accusé la preuve est déficiente
il est acquitté le parent est raffermi
sa légende des touches à
le narco trafic génère des millions de
dollars de l'argent qu'il faut blanchi
c'est qu'à montréal il se transigeait
des millions de dollars presque tous les
jours dans un cadre il à terre très
restreint du centre ville
si on avait eu des yeux rayons x le pont
on avait pu voir 80 des valises qui
provenaient des sacs de sport là on a
revu des liasses d'argent incroyable
déjà avait été surpris
la grc décide de tendre un piège aux
trafiquants en ouvrant un bureau de
change au centre ville de montréal
leur cible les colombiens mais ce sont
les italiens qui apporte le plus
d'argent et pas n'importe lesquels les
membres du clan rizutto des transactions
qui ont commencé que de tagada commence
à faire ici se sont fait absolument par
hasard on était même surpris nous de
savoir qu'ils n'étaient là et 7 après
enquête on s'est aperçu qu'ils étaient
joseph lakanal et qu'ils étaient sains
et l avocat de vito résultats
[Musique]
et ils étaient près de 6 était juste
l'autre côté de la rue au septième étage
et c'est un pur hasard que vous soyez un
stalinisme
pur hasard pure vérité
mais là ça
suffira pas même si la police relie
enfin vito rizutto blanchiment de
dizaines de millions de dollars
les côtes électronique et de si mauvaise
qualité que l'état ne peut pas porter
d'accusation contre lui au même moment
la police en a plein les bras avec la
guerre des motards deux clans
s'entretuent pour des territoires de
vente de drogue
la gare a coûté 160 de mort là dessus il
y en a huit que celle également des
innocents puis je pense que où ça change
aussi c'est quand l'enfant de 11 ans
fait tuer c'est là la population et de
ses dépôts acceptable
les trois corps de police du québec
unissent leurs efforts contre les
motards laissant le champ libre à la
mafia là on n'avait pas le choix et on a
trouvé des ongles qui pouvait descendre
des blocs à porte aval
ce qu'il leur faudrait qu'on protège la
population sow c'est vrai on a mis
toutes nos atouts
dans le comté motors h moman
ouais
en laisse
avec l'opération printemps 2001 et
l'arrestation de 142 membres des hells
angels
la police venait enfin d'ébranler les
piliers du crime à montréal au même
moment à new york
les anciens complices de vito rizutto
coincé par la police brise la loi du
silence
ils décident de collaborer avec les
autorités en échange de peine moins
sévère
plus de vingt ans après les meurtres
rizutto et trail de 12 m2 de capteurs et
night in roanne a dit que down the
beginning
[Musique]
l'époque bénie des risottos tire à sa
fin
petit à petit les policiers italiens
découvrent qu'ils sont les membres du
consortium mis en place par vito rizutto
et ils ont toute une surprise à la tête
du groupe
un ingénieur de 83 ans un citoyen au
dessus de tout soupçon
il pose
[Musique]
ce citoyen irréprochable s'appelle
giuseppe zappia à montréal on la mieux
connue sous le nom de joseph zappia
c'est lui qui avait décroché le contrat
de construction du village olympique
puis le scandale a éclaté
potdevin fausses factures zappia a été
accusé à montréal de fraude extorsion
il a fui la justice pendant des années
arrêté en suisse et ramener au canada à
pied a finalement été acquittés faute de
preuves
giuseppe zappia habite maintenant dans
ce beau quartier de rome
il n'a pas ouvert quand nous avons sonné
chez lui mais il est sorti sur son
balcon
en somme ces affaires on est dans
montréal
saint pierre se sera pas très long est
ce qu'on va vous parler au moment où on
a quelques questions vous posez josette
et appiah a refusé de nous parler
l'ingénieur est accusée d'association
avec la mafia
il peut difficilement prétendre qu'ils
ignoraient avec qui il faisait affaire
comme le prouve cette conversation
interceptée par la police
je souhaite implanter l'escouade anti
mafia s'est mis à suivre à pia en 2002
la filature les a conduits ici au très
chic hilton de rome le groupe criminel
s'est réuni pour parler d'argent
après la rencontre xavier a fait un
téléphone un téléphone de trop des
leading to defend quand les assauts des
fonds even if they try to be
j'attends seulement signal je suis
bresse on arrive à la fin du projet
n'ont de toute façon peu ils veulent
donner quelque chose mais je pense que
c'est pas assez et doivent se mettre
d'accord
cette imprudence a coûté cher à vito
rizutto la police italienne réclame son
extradition pour lui faire un procès et
l'arrestation du fils a forcé le père
nick à revenir à l'avant-scène
il a repris les commandes mais il a lui
aussi commis des erreurs on l'accuse
maintenant de plusieurs crimes à
montréal résultat il est en prison
[Musique]
dans le village natal des risottos une
petite place publique salue la mémoire
des victimes de la mafia en sicile des
juges des journalistes des hommes
d'affaires pour les gens d'ici
la mafia détruit non seulement
l'économie mais la paix sociale on doit
envoyer un message aux jeunes c'est
important qu'ils respectent la loi
le style de vie de la mafia est
inacceptable important des opéras de la
guitare
[Musique]
le cinéma a largement contribué à
projeter une image romantique des
mafiosos
en italie ce qui leur font la lutte ont
une toute autre vision de cet univers il
souhaiterait que les anglo saxons
prennent la mesure du danger que
représente le crime organisé les
canadiens lui demande encore ce qu'il y
à d'illégal dans l'investissement
d'argent dans le pont de miss de tout
des machines les clichés milliards
si le crime organisé injecte des
milliards de dollars dans l'économie
il a de l'impact surtout quand il à
l'approbation des politiciens économies
chine qui à leur bord tapas sont avérées
apogée diakhou nicoli des jeunes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus de cinquante ans après avoir quitté
l'italie les risottos comptait bien y
revenir pour profiter de leur retraite
et surtout de leur fortune
si l'on en croit à l'escouade anti mafia
le père et le fils reviendront bel et
bien dans leur pays d'origine mais
escorté par la police
ici on veut à tout prix que les chefs
mafieux répondent de leurs crimes devant
la justice italienne
non
m
[Musique]